الارهابي بالاضافه الى
التخلي عن الدعم تنظيم الارهابي هناك
التاخر ايضا في موضوع التاشيرات كانت هناك
التسارع كان هناك تسارع في
تقديم التاشيرات الى الاتراك وفي الاعمال
القنصليه ولكن فيما بعد حدث هناك بعض
البطء في تقديم التاشيرات بالنسبه ايضا
الى اغلاق القنصليه امنيه
من الضروري اعلام وزاره الخارجيه واخبار
وزاره الخارجيه التركيه في حال حصول اي من
تهديدات ارهابيه او ما شبه قبل اغلاق هذه
القنصليات فيجب ان يكون هناك قنوات تواصل
مباشره بين الاداره التركيه وبين المؤسسات
التركيه قبل التوجه الى اغلاق السفارات
والقنزليات لدواعم امنيه هناك بعض
الملفات الاخرى التي تحدثنا عنها في ملفات
المنطقه لن تطرقنا الى
توسع حلف شمال الاطلسي وتحدثنا ايضا عن
انضمام فنلندا والسويد الى شمال الاطلسي
وكنا قد ذكرنا انه من الضروري التزام كلا
الدولتين اولا بمذكر التفاهم الذي تم
التوقيع عليها وبعد ذلك سيتم النظر الى
انضمام الدولتين الى حلف شمال الاطلسات
تطرقنا ايضا انه سيتم تقييم كل هذه
الملفات بشكل مشترك وتطرقنا ايضا الى
القضيه الفلسطينيه وايضا
الى اسرائيل بالاضافه الى تصرفاتها تصرفات
اسرائيل العنيفه
وايضا وجدنا ان هناك بعض التصريحات
الايجابيه في هذا الصدد التي ادانت هذه
التصرفات الاسرائيليه في الاراضي
الفلسطينيه وايضا تطرقنا الملف السوري
وقيمنا المستجدات هناك
اليوم كانت هذه الاجتماعات
لديها كان لدينا كميات كبيره من الملفات
التي تطرقنا اليها نشكر وزير الخارجيه
الامريكيه على هذه
الزياره واشكر معاليه الوزير ايضا على
تقديمه الدعم لتركيا
شكرا جزيلا معالي الوزير الوزير الخارجيه
التركيه
فرصه
مهمه بالنسبه الينا زياره تركيا في هذه
الفتره وفي هذه الفتره العاصمه كان مهم
جدا وجدت حاملا رساله الرئيس الامريكي جو
بايدن وذلك ان الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
مستعده للوقوف الى جانب تركيا في هذه
الكارثه والتقديم كل ما يلزم للتقديم
المساعدات والدعم تركيا في هذه
الكارثه هذه الكارثه طبعا يوم امس قمنا
بزياره مدينه هاتاي المنكوبه
كما اتعلمون من الصعب ان اتحدث عن هذه
المشاهد التي كنا قد
وجهناها هناك الكثير من المباني المتضرره
والمنهره
كان هناك بعض الممثلين ايضا من
منظمه المجتمع المدني وايضا هناك الكثير
من رجال الانقاذ الذين قدموا الى تركيا
من
المدن والولايات الامريكيه الاخرى هناك
بعض المنظمات الرسميه التي وصلت الى هنا
بالاضافه الى
رجال الانقاذ الذين يعملون في منظمه الخوذ
البيضاء كانوا هنا يعملون في وشاركون في
عمليات البحث والانقاذ الرئيس الامريكي جو
بايدن
توجهها فورا الى تقديم
الاوامر للعديد من السياسيين وايضا
للمنظمات الحكوميه ومنظمات المجتمع المدني
لتقديم كل المساعدات اللازمه فورا الى هذه
المنطقه في تركيا في الجنوب التركي وفي
الشمال السوري هناك
العديد من
الخيام والمطابخ المتنقله وايضا الخيم
والمنازل المتنقله يتم تقديمها الى هذه
المنطقه وكما تعلمون هناك 100 دولار 100
مليون دولار
مساعدات اضافيه تم اقرارها لارسالها الى
المناطق المنكوبه هذه الفتره نحن مستعدون
لتقديم المساعدات
هناك مساعدات بمقدار 80 مليون دولار تصل
من الشركات الخاصه الامريكيه
وكان هناك كميات كبيره من المساعدات التي
يتم تقديمها ولذلك لم اتمكن من الدخول الى
هذه المناطق كما تعلمون هذه
هناك مرحله طويله ستعيشها تركيا ربما
لاعاده الاعمار
وبالتالي يجب ان نقف الى جانب تركيا طيله
هذه الفتره كما تعلمون كلما كانت
كلما كانت هذه
اننا نحن نقف الى الجانب تركيا في كل
الفترات العصيبه
ونحن
ايضا
نتفهم
هذه
المرحله العاصمه التي تمر منها تركيا
وكانت تركيا كما تعلمون تقدم كل الوسطات
اللازمه
لحل الازمه الاوكرانيه وانهاء الحرب
الروسيه الاوكرانيه ووقفت ايضا في
الى جانب الحل ايضا عندما
بادرت في ان تكون وسيطه لتمرير السفن
الحبوب
واخراجها من الموانع الاوكرانيه والروسيه
بالاضافه الى انها ساعدت كل المساعدات
الانسانيه وقدمت كل مساعده الانسانيه الى
اوكرانيا وايضا
ادخلت معاهده مونترو فورا بعد بدا الحرب
الروسيه الاوكرانيه هو ايضا هناك الكثير
من الملفات المهمه التي لتركيا دور فعال
فيها في هذه المنطقه منها غاز القوقاز
منها
السلام في هذه المنطقه ومبادرتها ايضا
للرفاه وبالتالي
تسعى تركيا ان تكون ان تكون دور فعال في
حلف شمال الاطلسي ولكن علينا ان نتحدث عن
ضروره توسع ان ضروره انضمام
الى حجر الان ان
دور تركيا ايضا في الملف الارميني والملف
اليوناني ايضا نرى ان ارمينيا واليونان
ايضا تعمل الى جانب تركيا في الكثير من
الملفات
وايضا ضمن حلف شمال الاطلسي كما تعلمون
لتركيا دور فعال في المنطقه
وهناك اتفاقيات تجاريه
مهمه بين الدولتين وطبعا هناك حجم تبادل
تجاريه يرتفع بشكل
تركيا لديها استثمار بحجم 16 مليار دولار
في الطاقه المتجدده وبالتالي الان هناك
الكثير من فرص الاستثمار والعمل وايضا خلق
فرص جديده
الكثير من المجالات هناك
مصالح مشتركه للبلدين وقيم مشتركه بين
البلدين وايضا نسعى لتحقيق كل المصالح هذه
من ضمنها الى حقوق الانسان وكما نتحدث عن
هذه المبادرات دوما
ويمكن ان تكون هناك بعض الخلافات بين
الدولتين ولكن تركيا والولايات المتحده
الامريكيه الدول الصديقه وبالتالي من
المهم ان تقف الى جانب بعضها البعض حتى
ولو كانت هناك بعض الخلافات السياسيه في
بعض الملفات ويمكننا التبادل الراي في هذه
الملفات حتى لو لم يكن هناك اتفاق تام في
هذه الملفات اليوم
ساتوجه ايضا الى
كبيره ضريح مؤسس الجمهوريه التركيه مصطفى
كمال اتاتورك واتوجه ايضا الى الضريحه كما
تعلمون ان هذه المنطقه مهما كان ارسل ايضا
لائحه
هذه المخطوطه كان
يتواجد يتواجد هنا في انقره للدعم الصداقه
المشتركه والعلاقات المشتركه بين تركيا
والولايات المتحده الامريكيه الان علينا
ان نحمل هذه العلاقات الى مستوى ابعد شكرا
جزيلا
سؤالي لمالي الوزيرين
الى طائرات اف 16 وبيع طائرات 16 هناك دعم
كبير من الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ولكن
الكونجرس ولديه يمنعوها متى من
ما هو الموعد النهائي ربما لتمرير هذا
القرار من الكونغرس لانه هناك رسائل
موجهه من الكونجرس الى الرئيس الامريكي
ما هي المعلومات النهائيه التي بايديكم
حول تمرير هذا القرار
تدعم
تدعم تركيا في هذا الاطار بما ان تركيا
وطبعا هناك مصالح مشتركه وبالتالي من
الضروري ان تكون لتركيا هذه القدره
المسلحه ايضا في
العمل الاستراتيجي ضمن ناحيه شمال الاطلسي
لا استطيع الان ان احدد موعد نهائي او
تقييم نهائي حول ذلك نحن نعطي المعلومات
الى الكونجرس واداره المتحده الامريكيه
الان هناك عمل
قائم الى حد الان طبعا هناك روابط امنيه
عميقه بين تركيا والولايات المتحده
الامريكيه والتحرك بشكل مشترك مهم بنسبه
الينا قبل قليل
كنت قد تطرقت الى هذا الملف هناك اراده
حكوميه وهناك بعض الرسائل التي صدرت من
الكونجرس وتم توجيها الى
الرئيس الامريكي بشكل مباشر طبعا اعمال
الممثلين الاتراك في الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه مستمره في هذا الصدد واذا استمر
هذا الضغط بهذه الطريقه اعتقد اتحدث عن
ضغط الاداره الامريكيه وايضا العمل في هذا
الملف بشكل مشترك فسيتم تمرير هذا القانون
حيث ان الكونجرس سيقتنع بهذه الضروره
اعتقد ليس عاد الان يتم تمرير الملفين
هناك شروط مختلفه
16 هناك مباحثات
منفصله
وهناك مذكرات تفاهم منفصله لذلك
الحديث عن ربط بين الربط بين هذين الملفين
الملفين ليس واقعي ليس عادل وبالتالي من
الضروري ان يتم ان يكون هناك موقف مشابه
لتركيا الولايات المتحده الامريكيه في هذا
الملف بالنسبه الى يعني اتحدث عن الملف
الاف 35
وال اف 16
كان هناك عقوبات مفروضه على تركيا وتم
اخراج تركيا عن اتفاقات اف 35
وهناك مبلغ تم دفعه من قبل تركيا يبلغ
مليار ونصف مليار تقريبا وبالتالي ضروري
الان ان ننتظر
استمرار هذه المباحثات وان اتدمن نتيجه
ايجابيه هناك خبراء مستمرين ببحث هذه
الملفات ومن الضروري الوصول الى نتيجه
واقعيه في اقصر وقت ممكن
هناك الكثير من الخلافات بين تركيا
والولايات المتحده الامريكيه انضمام اسود
وفنلندا الى حلف شمال الاطلسي ايضا الاس
435 وال f16 هناك الكثير من الملفات ولكن
الى جانب كل هذه الملفات هناك كارثه
عاشتها تركيا هل يمكن ان تكون هذه
الكارثه وسيله
للتعزيز العلاقات بين تركيا والولايات
المتحده الامريكيه من جديد وهل هناك
احتمال
او يتم الحديث
وخطه منتظره من ان توافق تركيا على انضمام
السويد
وفندا الى حلف شمال قبل القمه القادمه
[موسيقى]
هل يمكن ان يتم اعتبار هذه الكارثه اترجم
السؤال مره اخرى هل هناك خطه مرتقبه لرسم
خطه
زمنيه معينه بالنسبه
[موسيقى]
الى
الى ان يتم تمرير هذا القانون قانون اف 16
في الكونجرس شكرا جزيلا على السؤال
طبعا هذا
التضامن في الاوقات العاصمه يؤثر على
العلاقات المشتركه بشكل جيد
وهناك بعض الخلافات في
بعض الملفات وهذه واضحه ولكن الاجنده
الايجابيه والتركيز على الاجنده الايجابيه
يمكنها ان ترمي الى
تعزيز العلاقات في الكثير من الملفات
الاخرى وفي تعزيز العلاقات بين البلدين
بالنسبه الى
هي الاستراتيجيه كان قد تم اقرار تاسيس
اللجنه الاستراتيجيه كنت ذكرتها في بدايه
الهدف من هذه اللجنه هي التركيز على
الاجنده
الايجابيه والتركيز على الملفات التي
للدولتين تقارن في وجهات النظر وايضا
تعزيز القوه الامريكيه والتركيه في العمل
على السلام وارفعه في هذه المنطقه وايضا
عن هذه الملفات العالقه بين البلدين والتي
لديها لدينا فيها خلافات بالراي واختلافات
في الراي في هذه الملفات في هذه
الاجتماعات ذاتها حيث اننا نلتقي باستمرار
عندما
وصل كما تعلمون الوزاره وزير الخارجيه
اليونانيه الى تركيا
بعد حدوث هذه الكارثه لا ننتظر حدوث كوارث
تعزيز العلاقات المشتركه او العوده الى
الاجنده الايجابيه بين هذه الدول من
الضروري العمل اتفاقيه كما تعلمون مذكره
تفاهم تم التوقيع عليها من قبل السويد
وفنلندا وتركيا
وتاكدنا
انه من الضروري التزام الدوله التين بهذه
التعهدات
بالنسبه الى الخطوات التي سيتم اتخاذها
قبل
قبل ان يتو القادمه هناك بعض التغييرات في
الدستور هناك بعض التغييرات في القوانين
الضمنيه الاخرى في السويد ولكن كما تعلمون
ان
التظاهرات الارهابيه مستمره وايضا تمويل
الارهاب مستمره وتجنيد
الناس مستمره هناك باسود هذه الانشطه
موجوده هناك وامام مباني البلديات التي
تتواجد في العاصمه السويديه وبالتالي هذه
الانشطه يتم يجب ان يتم منعها من قبل
الاداره السويديه من قبل الحكومه السويديه
وهي لا تتخذ هذه الخطوات يعني الجميع الان
يراها عن قرب يعني هنا الجميع في تركيا
مثلا لديه على ضروره
الالتزام الاسود بهذه
القرارات التي تم التوقيع عليها في مذكره
التفاهم كلما التزمت السويد في هذه
التعهدات فسيتم
دخولها او
قبول دخولها الى الاطلسي فلندا ملفها اسهل
لان فنلندا تلتزم بهذه التعهدات وبمذكره
التفاهم وبالتالي يجب على السويد ان
خطوات ملموسه وان تشجع كل الاطراف على بذل
جهودها للالتزام بهذه التعهدات
شكرا جزيلا عزيزي ميلو تشاوش او
[موسيقى]
كنت قد ذكرت ذلك سابقا تركيا المتحده
الامريكيه
لديهم علاقات قويه في منطقه وفي العالم
وتعمل كلا الدولتين تعملا
قوي وفعال في العالم لا استطيع ان ارسم
اليكم خريطه زمنيه معينه لتمرير ربما هذا
القرار قرار اف 16 ولكن التركيه والولايات
المتحده الامريكيه لديهما القدره السياسيه
والعسكريه للعمل
بشكل قوي وفعل في العالم كنت قد ذكرت هذه
التفاصيل الان بالنسبه الى
توسيع العمل بشكل فعال هذا القرار
مطابق فمشاركه ربما ودخول السويد وفنلندا
ملفهما منفصل حاليا عن هذه الملفات نحن
طبعا ندعم انضمامتين دولتين الى الاطلسي
وتوسع الناتو بهذا الصدد
كل هذه الدول تعمل
بشكل عسكري عسكري فعال في هذه المنطقه
لذلك امن كل هذه المنطقه وايضا امن
واستقرار الشمال الاوروبي
تكون خطوتها مهمه
فالان هناك بعض الخطوات المتخذه ضمن
الاليه الثلاثيه
وايضا ضمن مذكره التفاهم التي تم التوقيع
عليها في مدريد هذه الخطوات قيمه بالنسبه
الينا
سؤالي لما
الامريكي انتوني بلانكن سؤال عن سوريا
بالتحديد في سوريا
هناك
بعض المخاوف التركيه في
تواجد هذه التنظيمات الارهابيه
والدعم المتحده الامريكيه لهذه التنظيمات
هل تم التطرق الى هذه الملفات
الاجتماعاتكم وهل هناك اي خطوات
من اجل
راحه ربما هذه المخاوف التركيه في الملف
الارهابي
شكرا على السؤال نعم نتحدث عن هذا الملف
وتطرقنا اليه
كما
ذكرتم انتم ايضا نحن
نتفهم مخاوف
قلق تركيا في الامن وفي
هذه التنظيمات الارهابيه
نتفهم هذه المخاوف التركيه ونعمل مع تركيا
من اجل مكافحه الارهاب ولكن هناك الان
ضروره لتقديم المساعدات الانسانيه في ظل
هذه الكوارث المدمره التي اصابت الشمال
السوري وجنوب التركي نحاول ونسعى الى
ايصال كل المساعدات الانسانيه
اللجنه الامنيه الان ستتخذ القرارات ربما
حيال ذلك ولكن
هناك
انشطه عسكريه روسيه
مع النظام السوري ولكن النظام السوري الان
يقول انه سيتم افتتاح معبرين حدوديين
لادخال المساعدات لذلك من الضروري الان
زياده
المساعدات وتقديم المساعدات
الانسانيه الى
المنكوبين هناك تقديم
المساعدات كان مهما ومنذ بدايه الثوره
السوريه والازمه السوريه هناك يتم تقديم
المساعدات الى سوريا كل المساعدات
الانسانيه الى الناس الى النازحين والى
الهاربين من
من الهجمات التي يقوم بها النظام ضروري
الان العمل على تقديم هذه المساعده
بالنسبه الى تعليقك
نحن نرى انهم من
الخاطئ ان يتم العمل مع تنظيم ارهابي من
اجل مكافحه تنظيم ارهابي اخر
وبالتالي
نحن
اثبتنا دائما
انه يجب مكافحه كل التنظيمات الارهابيه
ومكافحه كل التنظيمات الارهابيه مهما كانت
ايدولوجيتها ومهما كانت تفكير ومهما كان
صنفها وبالتالي اذا كان هناك
ايدولوجيتها ومهما كانت تفكيرها ومهما كان
سياسيه فيمكن مواجهه هذه التنظيمات
الارهابيه بشكل مشترك الان هناك تهديدين
لحب شمل الاطلس التهديد
[موسيقى]
وعدم تفضيلنا
تنظيم عن تنظيم اخر الان حصل
هناك كارثه وقعتونك كارثه وقع هناك زلازل
في الشمال السوري وجنوب التركي التقديم
المساعدات الانسانيه الى المدنيين واجبنا
الانساني اليس كذلك هو منظمات المجتمع
المدني والمنظمات الحكوميه وبعض الدول
تساعد تقدم المساعدات الى تركيا وتودي
هتودي هذه
المساعده ايضا الى سوريا عن طريق تركيا في
ايصال هذه المساعدات تعتبر من الواجب
الانساني للتركي لذلك نحن
نخرج او نفتح المعابر الحدوديه الى عن
طريق معبى عن طريق معبر بابل الهوى وايضا
عن طريق معبر كلس
[موسيقى]
ليتم كنا ذكرنا ان بامكان الامم المتحده
استخدام هذين المعبرين
لايصال المساعده الانسانيه الى
هناك بعض الشاحنات التي تحمل هذه
المساعدات الانسانيه الى عفرين وما بعدها
يتم كل تقديم كل المساعدات فيعجب علينا ان
نفصل بين السياسه وايضا عن المسؤوليه
الانسانيه نحن سنلقي هذه المعابر مفتوحه
لايصال المساعدات وشكرا ايضا على العمل
المشترك في هذا الاطار
ذكي
شكرا انا
بعض الصعوبات الان
السياسيا لانها تقدم المساعدات الى روسيا
هل ستفرض الولايات المتحده الامريكيه بعد
العقوبات على الصين
بالاضافه الى ذلك هل هناك اي خطوات متخذه
في ذلك
محطات في ايران
وتنشيط هذه المحط ايضا كيف ستنعكس هذه كيف
سينعكس هذا الملف ايضا على الملف اتفاق
الملف النووي
ايضا هناك بعض الاطراف التي تقدم
المساعدات الى روسيا
ما هو رايكم حياله ذلك بالنسبه الى الصين
وبالنسبه الى روسيا ذكرنا سابقا
وزملائي في الاداره الامريكيه ذكر ذلك
مجددا نحن
نراقب
بقلق هذه المساعدات الصينيه الى روسيا
وخصوصا في اطار الاسلحه نحن في واشنطن
نراقب هذا الملف
وكان رئيس الامريكي جو بايدن اتذكر ذلك
كما قد تحدث الى الرئيس الصيني في تلك
الاونه وتحدث ايضا ان هذا الملف سيكون ملف
مغاير لسياسات المشتركه بين اولياء
الاتفاقيات المشتركه بين بين الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه والصين هذا
هذه المساعدات
تتطلب عقوبات لا لا استطيع الان ان اتحدث
اليكم بلغه حاسمه لان المباحثات مستمره
المتابعات مستمره
شاركنا هذه المخاوف مع المسؤولين الصينيين
وربما يتطلب هذا الامر بعض العقوبات ولكن
الصين الان فهمت هذه المخاطر
وفي حال استمرارهم لتقديم المساعدات
العسكريه الى روسيا فسيتطلب الملف الان
بعض العقوبات التي بامكاننا ان نفرضها على
السن لذلك الان الصين فهمت هذا الامر
بامكان ان يتم اتخاذ بعض الخطوات اللازمه
لاتخاذ تدميرنا ايضا في هذا الامر
وبالتالي
اعتقد ان السن الان
تتوقف ربما عن تقديم الدعم بالنسبه الى
الطاقه الذريه وبالنسبه الى ملف الطاقه
الذريه الان نستمر ايضا بالمباحثات مع مع
الحلفاء الاوروبيين نبحث عن الكثير من
المعلومات ونجمع المعلومات هذا الموضوع
للغايه ولا يمكن الحديث عنه في بشكل دقيق
الان
بدايه الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه كانت
تركيا لديها مواقف
ثابته
ونحن ندعم وحده الاراضي الاوكرانيه
لا نعترف
بالاستفتاء من جانب واحد والغير قانوني
وايضا ضم الاراضي بشكل غير قانوني الى
روسيا
مواقف تركيا واضحه جدا حيث انها تنفذ ايضا
اتفاقيه مونرو بشكل واقعي وبشكلا
حساس للغايه ايضا نستمر بالمباحثات بين
الجانب الروسي وبين الجانب الاوكراني بشكل
منفصل
ولن نسمح الى مرور كما اننا لم نسمح الى
مرور اي سفينه عسكريه عبر مياه البحر
الاسود
ولكن تركيا لا تشارك بفرض العقوبات يعني
نحن لا
نشارك بفرض العقوبات من جانبا واحد طبعا
ونحن نوافق على اتخاذ بعض القرارات مع
الامم المتحده مثلا كيف يمكن مواجهه
الارهاب كيف يمكن مثلا مواجهه ايدولوجيه
فاصله بين الدول ولكن من جانب اخر
ان نرى ان العقوبات الاوروبيه وعقوبات
المتحده الامريكيه
لا يمكن ان تكون عبر تركيا يعني تركيا لن
تسمح لي ان تكون هذه العقوبات او ان تركيا
تكون جزءا من هذه العقوبات او الزر
الخزانه والماليه الامريكي كان هنا في
تركيا
زار تركيا وكان هناك بعض المعلومات
والملفات التي تصل الى تركيا ما انتبه الى
هذه الملفات
طبعا نناقش كل هذه الملفات نرى ان بعض
الملفات بالفعل ضروري اتخاذ تدابير واتخاذ
الاحتياطات الممكنه فبعض المنتجات
الاوروبيه تصل الى تركيا
تصديرها مثلا الى روسيا نتخذ ايضا هذه
التدابير الى عدم تصدير هذه البضائع
والسلع الى روسيا عن طريق تركيا نعم هناك
حجم تبادل تجاري مرتفع ولكن 60% منها كحجم
اتحدث هي
الغاز الطبيعي وايضا بعض مواد الطاقه طبعا
الان
اسعار الغاز الطبيعي تضاعفت بثلاث اضعاف
تقريبا التي ندفعها الى روسيا هناك بعض
المواد الغذائيه ايضا التي نصدرها الى
روسيا ولكن هي ليست
المواد الاوروبيه او الامريكيه يعني نحن
كما ذكرنا اننا نسعى الى تكون جزءا من هذه
العقوبات ونحن
الصادقين
هذه مع هذه التي فاذا كان هناك اي وثائق
تدل على ذلك الاتحاد الاوروبي بامكانها ان
تقدمه لنا واذا كان هناك اي خلل في ذلك او
عدم التزام في ذلك سننتخذ كل التدابير
اللازمه شكرا